so I can't I can't stick can't get the
idea even then you're reduced to
deflection deflection is reactionary the
deflection doesn't work at full speed
which is why it's being substituted by
setups right you throw your jab I catch
the gym and I come back over the counter
yeah you throw your jab I need to set
the traditional martial art solution -
it was not set ups because setups and
setup
[Music]
or the dilemma that you set up - the
adhesion or okay when weapons are modern
balls and weapons are very hot so make
connection then you keep connection
deflection setup dilemmas they're topics
they're viable but under different rules
under different scenarios you will use
them in combination with I'm not they're
not useless they're not invaluable but
there may be much more valuable when you
can combine them with you guys used to
be somebody who is getting countered by
setups and dilemmas getting trapped and
dilemmas face paints things like that
they look for connection
but if you're doing Aikido you're trying
to do a Kido humor it's all based on the
height adhesion it's a different art let
me ask you guys a question don't get
flattered
okay
you and se are obviously free to choose
what part of the training to do and
don't you it's kind of your mic isn't it
like if I took it away from you kind of
do you afford that same entitlement to
your teacher can I extremely pick and
choose who and would you feel robbed
you feel robbed okay so there's
something weird going on you see that it
doesn't see her if you're free to be and
she's actually somehow okay
we will be just as happy a lot of media
picking shoes as you are satisfied you
pick
personally I don't think it works even
in that I'd realize the world I don't
think it works because there's certain
elements and aspects that not would be
in place in order for you to progress we
call that progressions because you have
to have this to do that to do that to do
that to do that it is no different than
I can't take you to the range if you
cannot safely operate the firearm you
have to have that before we go
so when I say go do that technique over
there I'll tell you I'm going to share
with you my points of view
the first thing that happened is I said
to do an IP adhesion and then you did
deflections okay then we have a separate
the clouds because if you're going to do
a our deflections this just that would
speed reinforce together it does nothing
to do with what I want I don't want you
to do it our reflections but if I let
you do our reflections you really create
deflections and deflections are not as
good as you think they are nor are they
the arms okay so then we said okay you
guys aren't going to do this anymore but
did you think I would do our reflections
you would be further from I can't even
wait if you keep looking then I said
change partners mix it up
then we just thought they went to the
old drill and then you guys think
techniques you're basically doing t1 was
do you understand that
so if I wait for you to grab me and I
pick the technique ahead of time that is
just an extra dime Hakeem applause you
see how that is not G was that is I just
reconciled his energy and technique
manifests itself
do you understand so now you're doing
chemo mother energy wanted to say that's
also not right then some of you kept
doing the company grow
[Music]
when you stop doing chemo then you're
stopping them in your classroom that
then you're not taking candy you're
trying to beat them the same
reconciliation of an energy that you
would do it is the same reconciliation
to deduce an object but the person who
passion is a detested spook it what do
you think they are as target the person
who contested classes is not yet now
that we get stop pooping when you do
that as not yet and now again this is
not right
does not work especially when you're
much smaller than the other person but I
okay so when the teacher says we're
going to do this and it's not that it
has to come from you from within you
that you stop that I cannot do that
okay and I would say that there is a
deeper art when you can stop that the
same the same release that you do where
you don't contest the bouquet that is
coming in when you accept what they're
doing is the same release and the
acceptance you practice with the
teachers direction where you stop
choosing and filtering you see because I
our ego or pride or lack of experience
wants us to do the other thing but you
get to practice releasing and acceptance
but you also get another time you get
the stepping stone necessary for the
next riddle okay so GE was a number one
progression that we do if you guys are
asked to do over here is not Kiyomasa
done without brace and change the
technique every breath that's just yes
it's so what would what would we say is
the difference that it could be the same
technique but what makes one technique
application G was that and what makes it
yeah
I think that's a pretty good definition
okay pretty good
can you see it seems like but wait it's
the same technique but the emotional
psychological spiritual content that the
core of the technique is entirely
different and if you don't think that
matters sooner maybe get kissed by
someone you don't want to kiss that is
so depressing the lips on lips and you
don't want nothing to do with it okay
the emotional spiritual content counts
and you need to be able to have that
allow me the technique to just happen to
start moving into the countering the
wrong Dori the strikes the transcendence
of form which is the solution
not more form I don't want to know
another freaking technique for the left
hook I want to stop being bogged down by
technique then it doesn't matter what
okay do you guys so it's very hard isn't
it it's like doing salsa and trying to
stop thinking the same exact thing
saves that problem it's the problem of
the mind and the everyday mind
utilization and preoccupation and
enslave head to form it's the same okay
okay so we're going to hit us again next
week and just like when you do solve
them you have a beginner tool return to
your posture so your mind goes off
return to posture okay she was a
beginner drill is don't think technique
you're gonna go you'll be able to do it
get your mind on the energy that's pushy
do you see that bring your mind to the
sensation after contact